that's a good point and do you believe
that we can lose eternal life like if we
go into apostasy would we lose it well
the there is ample scripture and the
predominant view of the church has been
that someone who refuses to walk in
Union with the Holy Spirit and chooses
to walk away from the Holy Spirit can be
cut off from the Salvation that the
spirit has given that individual this
has been the majority position and
there's plenty of scripture to back that
up W yeah you see Ro SOL at first I
thought maybe you were a calvinist but I
used to be an orthodox guy my friend I
used to be you know what happened us to
yes I used to be a five point and it's
not there are Calvinists who love Jesus
Christ who are on fire for the Lord who
are geniuses like Anthony Rogers the
reason why I change is because like
you I embraced a view that I thought was
scriptural and hopefully like me you'll
be praying to the holy spirit to guide
you in all truth because when I told the
Holy Spirit please show me what is true
show me what is false and open my mind
and heart to the fullness of the truth
no matter where it is and I'll accept it
and the Holy Spirit start working in my
life messing my life up making me
miserable and uncomfortable with facts
that I was discovering until I fully
submitted oh wow so I've been where
you're at I've been where you're at
where I held two of you thought it was
right but when I asked the Holy Spirit
to show me and he started showing me it
started messing me up and I started
going back and forth like you you know
one day believe one thing next day
doubting it until finally I said you
know what the facts are clearly before
my eyes why am I fighting I submit and I
yield right do the same at least when it
comes to the Trinity because knowing the
right God and the true God is a matter
of Salvation because Jesus said in John
8:24 unless you believe I am you shall
die in your sins in other words you
better have the right Jesus and know who
Jesus is because the wrong Jesus that
Satan has produced and erected to
mislead you from the true Jesus will not
save you but damn you and that's second
Corinthians 11 read for me 2 Corinthians
11 veres 2- 4 read it for me okay second
Corinthians 11 verses 2-
4 it says here
okay so verse three and four two to four
oh two to
four says uh for I'm jealous for you
with Godly jealousy for I have Beth you
to one husband that I may present you as
a Chast virgin to Christ but I fear lest
somehow as the serpent deceived Eve by
his craftiness so your minds may be
corrupted from the Simplicity that is in
Christ
for he who comes and preaches another
Jesus whom we have not preached or if
you receive a different Spirit which you
have not received or a different gospel
which you have not accepted you may well
put up with it you see what Paul is
warning you the serpent is going to
seduce you from your spiritual Purity by
sending someone to preach to another
Jesus and present to you a different
spirit and present a different gospel in
other words the Jesus of modalism is
another Jesus from the Jesus of
Unitarianism right just like Mormonism
and uh thank you Jo Witnesses I Think
Jesus is Michael the Archangel so my
point Daniel my brother in humanity and
hopefully my brother in Jesus Christ it
is not a joke
to profess the wrong Jesus you have to
have the right Jesus because the wrong
Jesus can't sa you save you that is a
satanic counterfeit to Dam your soul to
hell all yeah I don't want to go to hell
at any cost you know I mean so if you
have an Eastern Orthodox Church in your
area do you have
one yeah I think there's one in the
Tampa area I live over by Tampa Florida
okay I have you been there before Sam no
I've been in Florida but I don't think
I've been there but do yourself a favor
as soon as you have time contact them
say look I was in this modalist church
that denied the Trinity now I just want
the truth and I'm open to hearing what
the truth is and I've been told the
Eastern Orthodox Church is an ancient
Church started by the apostles and I
want to hear why you believe in the
Trinity what's the biblical and
historical basis and what did the church
believe and you're you're on your way
home worship and love the Trinity friend
the Trinity is the only true God do not
turn to any other God even if they claim
that God is the god of the Bible the
moralist God cannot save you it's a
satanic counterfeit it's not the real
Jesus save yourself by being open to the
truth of who God is and when I say save
yourself meaning here the holy spirit is
speaking to you saying look moralism is
not true it's not biblical the true God
is Triune here accept the true God and
be saved because the true God is in love
with you so are you going to accept it
that's between you and the Holy Spirit
yes sir because also scripture says
Antichrist is denying the father and the
son yep and you are denying the father
and the son because you're perverting
the relationship between the father and
son you have a false father and a
different son and neither one can save
you right does that make sense I
appreciate speaking the truth no my
friend I appreciate you you know why
because you first came off as someone
attacking Trinity I thought you're gonna
blashe but now that you came on and you
have a sincere heart call me anytime
with any question and I'll spend as much
time answering your objections I promise
you but right now go to my YouTube
channel put in the Trinity watch all the
sessions on the Trinity find Anthony
Rogers Anthony Rogers has his own
channel he does sessions on the Old
Testament foundation of the Trinity go
to my blog and type in Trinity
read soak it up sature itself with all
the biblical proofs and reputations to
anti-trinitarian
theologies the evidence is there it's
clear and if you're open you will
worship and love the Triune God I
promise you okay thanks bro God bless
take care Daniel and the Lord Jesus
guide you to the true Christ the only
Christ who who can save you who's in
love with you amen take care
Daniel bye okay pray for him his name is
Daniel fredman see these are the kind of
people I'm looking for even if you're an
anti-trinitarian even if you're an
anti-trinitarian as long as you can be
respectful not mock the Trinity not
blashe the Trinity you can ask me any
question you can ask me many questions
no matter how tough I promise you I'll
answer to the best of my ability
provided you don't blaspheme the God
blaspheme the Bible and insult and mock
otherwise I'm going to have to give you
a taste of your medicine